now do you think
social media as a medium changed the
cultural standards
and i mean it in a have you read neil
postman at all have you read like
amusing ourselves to death he was a
social critic technology critic
and wrote a lot about sort of
technological determinism so
the ways which is a really influential
idea to a lot of my work which is
actually a little out of fashion right
now in academia but the ways that the
the properties and presence of
technologies change things about humans
in a way that's not really intended or
planned by the humans themselves and he
is the book is all about how
different communication medium like
fundamentally just changed the way the
human brain
understands and operates and so he sort
of gets into the what happened when the
printed word was widespread and how
television changed it
and this was all pre-social media but
this one these ideas i'm having is like
what's the degree to which i get into it
sometimes
on my show again to a little bit like
the degree to which like twitter in
particular
just changed the way that people
conceptualized what for example
debate and discussion was like it
introduced a rhetorical dunk culture
where it's sort of more about tribes not
giving ground to other tribes and
and it's like it's a complete there's
different places and times
when that type of discussion was thought
of differently right
well yeah absolutely but i i tend to
believe i don't know what you think that
there's the technological solutions like
there's literally different features in
twitter that could completely reverse
that there's so much power in the
different
choices yeah that are made and it could
still be
highly engaging and have very different
effects perhaps more negative but
or hopefully more positive yeah so i'm
trying to pull these two things apart so
there's these
two ways social media let's say could
change the experience of reading a
major newspaper today one could be a
little bit more economic right so
so the internet made it cheaper to get
news the newspapers had to retreat to a
paywall model because it was the only
way they were going to survive but once
you're in a paywall model then then
what you really want to do is make your
tribe which is within the paywall very
very happy with you so you want to work
to them but then there's the sort of
the determinist point of view which is
the properties of twitter which were
arbitrary
jack and evan just whatever let's just
do it this way
influence the very way that people now
understand and think about the world so
the
one influenced the other i think yeah
they they kind of
started adjusting together i i did this
thing i mean
i'm trying to understand this part of
the part of the
i've been playing with a the
entrepreneurial idea that's a very
particular
dream i've had of a startup that
this is a longer-term thing it has to do
with artificial intelligence
but more and more it seems like there's
some trajectory through
creating uh social media type of
technologies
very different than what people are
thinking i'm doing but
it's a kind of challenge to the way the
twitter is done but it's not obvious
what the best mechanisms
are to still make an exceptionally
engaging platform
my clubhouse is very engaging and not
have any of the negative effects
i for example there's uh chrome
extensions that
allow you to turn off all likes and
dislikes and all of that
from twitter so you all you're seeing is
just the content
yeah on twitter that to me is creates
that's not a compelling experience at
all because i still
need i would argue i still need the
likes to know what's a tweet worth
reading
yeah because i don't only have a limited
amount of time so i need to know
what's valuable it's like great yelp
reviews on tweets or something
exactly but i've turned off on
for example on my account on youtube
i've
turned uh i wrote a chrome extension
that turns off
all likes and dislikes and just views
yeah i don't know how many views the
video gets
and so yeah unless it's on my phone but
you take off the recommendations
uh the no youtube some people the
distraction for youtube is a big one for
people yeah no i'm not worried about the
distraction because
i'm able to control myself on youtube
you don't rap at all
no i don't rabbit hole so you have to
know your demons or your addictions or
whatever
on youtube i'm okay i don't have i don't
keep clicking
the negative feelings come from seeing
the views
on on stuff you've created have created
oh so you don't want to see your views
yeah so like i'm just like speaking to
the things that i'm aware of myself that
yeah are helpful and things that are not
helpful emotionally
yeah and i feel like there should be we
need to create actually tooling for
ourselves
that's not me with javascript but
anybody is able to
create sort of control the experience
they that they have yeah
you